hello everyone and welcome back to
versus I'm your host Mark Ellis if
you're new here welcome we have punch
and cookies let me tell you how this
program works you see we at versus take
art and make it competitive sometimes it
can get tough and we have to remove the
gloves off of two Academy award-winning
filmmakers or movies or performers other
times it's Robocop versus Terminator
that are alive you are coming with me
and today that whole art getting
competitive thing kicks into high gear
with moves like a body slam or a kill
switch or a the people's elbow not only
do I have three distinguished actors on
the show today who will not physically
be in this room that'd be very
intimidating for my little water pistols
but they've all forged a bountiful
career on the big screen after making
their debut on the world stage with
wrestling that's right we're cooking up
a worldwide wrestling winner take all
match featuring Dwayne The Rock Johnson
John Cena and Dave Batista in one corner
you have the rock he's that little blue
pill that every franchise craves and
he's made his Mark in everything from
fast and Furious movies to the world of
DC with Black Adam I kneel before no one
in the next corner is John Cena who
kicked off his Hollywood career with fun
actioners like the Marine before hitting
it big with comedies and the DC property
The Suicide Squad Peacemaker
it's actually very nice and in the third
and final corner it's a triangle ring
today kiddos we have Dave Batista who
can go from high profile sci-fi like
Blade Runner 2049 to cracking jokes in
the MCU as Drax in the Guardians of the
Galaxy movies
three tremendous careers approximately a
billion hours combined in the gym and
damn near a trillion bucks earned in
ticket sold pay-per-views witnessed and
merchandise generated but there's only
one belt and it's so big and shiny that
even in Old School Texas Cowboy would
say that's some Buckle why are you
wearing it on your shoulder son it's a
good pickup line here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score round three characters round four
iconic moments and then we'll do a Wild
Card round that just might involve a
bunch of begging from me that the two
losers of today's match don't take it
personally and challenge me to a push-up
contest I can now do seven of the
diamond ones without crying I will be
eat your ass like a Cherokee drum this
versus episode will feature their
Tinseltown careers as opposed to their
exploits in the ring but will Pepper in
some oiled up spice into the festivities
to give it some seasoning it's three of
the greatest most popular wrestlers of
this Millennium who've made the leap
from The Ring to the screen big and
small and now they Delight audiences of
all ages and just about every section
that Blockbuster Video has to offer and
that's not past tense by the way there's
still one in Bend Oregon and I hear it's
going strong and I think I have like 30
dollars in late fees there okay everyone
ready crowd set cue the music get on
your feet and let's get it on I don't
want to get sued by a buffer today we
are
foreign
box office
and now dear viewer I make you a promise
the match that ensues today will likely
come down to the wire it'll be super
tight and there's no real losers here
just one performer who's a little more
winier than the other two but in this
round John Cena and Dave Batista are
facing a mountain named Dwayne who
coincidentally is the guy from Race to
Witch Mountain will you remind him that
I'm a man and he's a dog and even if
that Witch Mountain movie isn't the
first film that comes to mind when I say
the rock it's still made over a hundred
million dollars worldwide so did Planet
51 and the tooth fairy in The Scorpion
King which was his debut in a starring
role those kind of numbers alone would
make him tough to beat in this round but
those movies aren't why they call him
movie franchise Cialis that is going to
work the dude has been in two movies
that have grossed over a billion dollars
at the box office Furious 7 hauled in
1.5 billion dollars and the fate of the
Furious which I'll give anyone one
dollar if they can tell me which one
that is in the franchise made 1.2
billion bones he got close to another
bill with Jumanji Welcome To The Jungle
which fun and gamed its way to a 961
million dollar Hall the sequel
accurately titled the next level grossed
798 million dollars so this guy's got
the goods
before I continue to run down that's
another movie he's in add 80 million
more into the bank under the name
Johnson let's see if his opponents have
a prayer of keeping pace so far actually
they do their lack of pharmaceutical
friendly nicknames aside Cena and
Batista both boast their own series of
gaudy digits Johnny nope I feel really
weird saying I'm sorry just like the
rock sees his best Blockbuster as a part
of the fast Saga and his participation
in part nine as a long lost relative
yeah that helped take in 721 million
dollars he also steered in the world of
Transformers and Bumblebee was certainly
more than meets the eye Computing 465
million dollars worth of coin and fair
warning that movie's opening eight
minutes on Cybertron is maybe the best
best short film ever created it might be
the best piece of art in the history of
humans or robots it as the kids say
slaps
[Applause]
Cena also popped into the Daddy's home
flicks and those two films tag team to
generate over 400 million dollars and
not even a pandemic could dampen the
spirits of The Suicide Squad which would
Notch 167 million dollars seeing his
comedies perform admirably as well and
he's great in them as evidenced by
blockers is 94 million dollars and train
wrecks 141 million bones so as huge as
those pie slices are they're probably
not enough to take down the feast
currently being gorged by The Rock how
about you Davey yeah everyone knows no
yeah I definitely should not call him
that step right up it won't hurt that
long what Dave Batista has the highest
and second highest grossing film of any
competitor in the show today even you
Dwayne hello
remember those Avengers movies yeah they
tend to do okay and Drax was featured in
both Avengers Infinity war and end game
both of which broke the bank with over 2
billion dollars each end game almost got
to three bills and is in constant
competition with Avatar as the who can
re-release itself more to claim the
all-time worldwide box office Crown
from there Batista can also brag about
the 007 feature Specter which grossed
879 million dollars Dune which generated
almost 400 million dollars worth of
spice and Blade Runner 2049 as that
long-awaited sequel notched 258 million
dollars oh and he's not done with the
MCU so far the two Guardians films have
combined for over 1.6 billion dollars
and Thor love and thunder and Roses
earned 737 million dollars and Drax was
there for a fun sequence featuring Guns
and Roses yeah that band really gets
around keep your eye on them well sweet
children it looks like a runaway victory
for the rock but Cena and Batista have
posted enough winning returns to make me
do a ton more math all told John Cena
movies have taken in 2.2 billion dollars
making for a per movie average of 197
million that's what the old-timers call
boffo what then we have Batista whose
MCA resume AIDS him in generating almost
9 billion dollars resulting in an
astonishing are you sitting down 528
million dollars per movie okay hang on
my Jaws on the floor I'll pick it up
that pummels the Rocks average of 348
million dollars and that's the first
time in history the 300 million dollars
sounds like jump change but The Rock has
been at this film Game longer and his
flicks all together make for 12.2
billion dollars worldwide okay so Dwayne
has the better raw number Dave has the
better average Batista is welcome as
Drax for any big screen Adventure or
birthday party that I throw for myself
but when you consider the totality of
everything going on in the MCU it wasn't
necessarily his might that propelled The
Avengers films to the record-breaking
totals and it's true The Rock was just
one of many crucial pieces in the fast
and Furious films but he also may have
been the reason those movies rebounded
from being a series with diminishing
returns into a true bankable Blockbuster
Endeavor beginning with Rocky's first
tussle with Ben in Fast Five that flick
took in 630 million dollars which is
three million dollars less than Moana
and it set the double F's on a path of
Bank deposits that still going strong
today Dwayne wins a surprisingly
competitive round one and he's on the
board first one to nothing to nothing
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score money is great it makes the world
go round but it can't buy happiness yeah
maybe it can put a pin in that but what
it can't do is change how we feel about
a film after we see it or in the case of
many MCU and DC properties after we see
it again and again and again they're all
really enjoyable these guys
but is that how the critics felt about
these films after witnessing it the
Tomato Meter will reveal all and what it
doesn't show us the audience score is
there representing us the people whose
Champ I still think is the rock is that
right
I currently also love Liv Morgan who is
a guest on my podcast Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong we talked about saw a whole lot it
was good times John Cena and Dave
Batista were smart to let Dwayne make
his career transition first because for
Johnson it wasn't all sunshine to begin
but Batista made an impact right away
pitching into the man with the iron fist
and then Riddick which hit an almost
fresh 51 and 57 respectively on the
Tomato Meter then he hit fresh town as
Guardians of the Galaxy scored a 92
percent then Volume 2 held strong with
an 85 percent that ties it with infinity
war and then end game came out and we
all cried and cheered and went back for
more and apparently so did the critics
it's 94 on the meter day tomato he's on
a nice fresh jog currently as Army of
the Dead Dune and Thor 11 Thunder are
all safely in fresh territory John Cena
got kicked off of the multiplex with the
aforementioned Marine it's a fun action
movie and it's got a very clever
Terminator reference with Robert frickin
Patrick standing right there it should
have been a fresh film just for that but
it gets weighed down at 7 19 percent
from there it was a rotten struggle with
movies like legendary and the reunion
but then we saw another side of Cena in
train wreck as one of Amy Schumer's
romantic liaison the movie nailed it
with an 84 percent on the TM then
sisters also got fresh with 60 even
bumblebee ranks is his all-time best in
terms of movies with a 91 followed
closely by The Suicide Squad at 90 and
blockers at 84 percent and I know we all
love Dwayne as Maui and Moana but let's
not forget that Cena's animated hit
Ferdinand is fresh at 71 percent oh mama
and now on to Johnson whose career
started Rocky with some negative
critical reactions for his first handful
of starring role in fact his first dozen
feature films only have one fresh movie
emerge and it's you guessed it the
rundown Gridiron Gang Southland Tales
and Race to Witch Mountain all landed in
the 40 range and it wasn't until the
other guys that he scored another fresh
film when that 2010 I'll call it a
classic chuckled up 78 that's also the
Tomato Meter numeral for fast 5 and more
freshness was to follow both Jumanji
films are in the 70 set fighting with my
family is 93 and Moana tops everyone
with a 95 but I will point out that
Cena's starring turn in The Peacemaker
streaming show is at 94 and it earns
that just for the opening credits alone
the audience score favors the rock as
barely fresh movies like jungle cruises
62 Tomato Meter number speed up to 92
percent with the audience score metric
that's also the best percentage audience
film for Dave Batista who wins that
courtesy of Guardians of the Galaxy John
Cena's best audience output are the twin
82 generated by The Suicide Squad and
fast nine so let's go once again to the
law of averages The Rock's audience
score gets into fresh territory with a
64 average across all his film that tops
both Batista's 47 and Cena's 56 but the
all-time average King for the Tomato
Meter is not Dwayne his average is 52
percent which is better than John Cena's
46 percent but it can't match Dave's 56
percent and since the Tomato Meter came
first that's the tiebreaker age before
Beauty even though I think Batista is
younger than the rock look they're all
beautiful but Dave Batista takes the win
in a nail biting round two and we're
tied at the top one to one and now John
Cena hopes to get on the board in round
three
round three character like I said Cena
is itching to tie this thing up at the
top by winning his first round of the
day and if he pulls it off here it'll be
on the strength of his character work
outside of the Ring not you Ferdinand
you can stay in that Arena and still
gain credit and I will say the niece and
the nephews love them some Ferdinand so
does Uncle Mark yeah I know but still
when I come to visit my siblings and
maybe borrow money there seems to be a
prevalent Hawaiian theme in the kiddos's
playroom Moana was not just another
rousing success for Disney animation and
their stunning Legacy it showcased the
rock being a fun personality who could
also poke fun at himself and he even
gets to croon a little bit Maui may not
be the first character that comes to
mind when and we think of this wrestling
hunk but this new generation coming up I
think they're called generation Alpha is
what we do with the Tykes gotta be [ __ ]
get it together they love them some
Moana and since Dwayne was the alpha at
the movies first he got to be the
Scorpion King in a big time franchise
like the mummy then he stuck close to
his action roots in bangers like the
rundown Walking Tall and doom the
standout for me is his role as Beck in
the rundown and despite all the great
action that that film does have for me
my favorite part is the quick blink and
you'll miss it moment near the film's
outset Beck is heading into a nightclub
to bash some football skulls and who
does he pass in the hallway
the guy on his way out of the club is
Arnold Schwarzenegger it's a fun Cameo
on the surface but the deeper meaning
yes I found deeper meaning in this scene
represents a passing of the torch from
the Terminator turned governator to a
new action hero for this Millennium The
Rock and with subsequent roles like
Hobbes in the fast films roadblock and
GI Joe and freaking Hercules I'd say he
carries that torch pretty well quite
literally in the case of Hercules old
previously played by Arnold the
multi-time Mr Olympia but to win a
character-based round the Wayne's gonna
have to keep the pressure up on these up
and comers they had the luxury of
studying his career and making choices
based on what worked and what didn't for
Johnson don't push me John Cena did the
action thing as John Triton in the
Marine but then was able to quickly
Branch out to Comedy and Astound us with
his brilliant seriously the dude can
nail a line just like a train wreck
Daddy's home and especially blockers
remember
stab turn Dragon I don't have the knife
yes you do check your clutch as Mitchell
the George sporting overprotective dad
of a high score he teams up with fellow
rents like Ike Baron Holtz and Leslie
Mann to form a trio of fall down funny
Guardians watching their babies grow up
too fast Dave Batista can also Veer into
yucks as evidenced with his most popular
role Drax nothing goes over my head my
reflexes are too fast a guy nicknamed
The Destroyer may not have earned it by
conquering worlds so much as making us
roll in the aisles opening weekend it's
a testament to his timing that he can
hang with and steal scenes from a
talking raccoon a sentient tree and all
the other goofiness that ensues in that
franchise of course he can also take on
some more serious action as well James
Bond prefers to be the only cheeky one
in his flicks so as Hank's inspector
Dave settles for kicking lots of ass
with minimal dialogue in more recent
films Batista has extended his range to
include leading movies like Army of the
Dead in which his Scott Ward faces
Undead hordes of evil and in stuber
where cop Vic Manning is able to both
Drive the action and keep up the chuckle
Pace alongside the great comedian
Camille nanjani who's now also in the
MCU what a fun Treehouse they must have
and big
yes but Dave still hasn't had the Reps
of Johnson who's been able to Star an
action vehicles that steer more towards
a dramatic family angle no I'm being
serious think about Rampage San Andreas
and I know skyscraper was probably sold
on that impossible building to building
leap that he pulls off can someone tell
Tom Cruise that it wasn't real I don't
want him Tom relaxed you've done enough
just
Dwayne Johnson stars as will Sawyer and
was saving his family's motivation he
had some emotional weight to the summer
popcorn storyline what really impressed
me was his role in Snitch he plays John
Matthews who gets into some Tangles that
may not be strictly legal but the
dramatic twist the movie takes show off
a deeper more emotional Rock who's not
just relying on his biceps to win the
day but for me John Cena has done so
much in such a short period of time when
it comes to establishing range as an
actor if he can't quite match the chops
harness by The Rock he might have
already one Upton in terms of raunchy
comedy that maybe a little adult
oriented but come on the kids are going
to see that anyway probably on their own
phone in public without airpods I don't
need to hear your cellular device it was
just really nice what you said it seems
like every actioner comedy or other
flick John Cena's done thus far has led
him to his role as Peacemaker and James
Gunn has been able to provide a Sandbox
that Cena dominates with Adept ability
that no one could have seen coming he's
funny in multiple ways ranging from
sarcastic to goofy to South deprecating
to blissfully unaware oh and he also
knows his way around a fight it's
certainly not the only role where he
showcases his versatility but it may be
the best example of anyone in contention
today without the aid of a rock-sized
resume or the MCU buddies pitching in
John Cena has still established himself
as a bankable star regardless of what
genre film you want to make hero villain
lead sidekick the guy can do it all and
with a CGI Eagle oh my God
he's hugging me Cena sneaks up on Dave
and Dwayne and steals round three and
now we're all tied up one to one to one
this is amazing round four iconic
moments characters much like their box
office coin that their films create are
awesome but movies and TV shows are more
than just cool looking posters and with
stars like these we want to be leaving
the theater not remembering someone's
name or costume or pet eagle we want to
be gushing about all those cool parts
that made us odd shocked crying laughing
you know the ones that get us that
Second tub of popcorn if we're looking
at the best sequences scenes and
segments in the movie library of these
fellas you got to start with the action
right and from the word go and that
first gear shift the audience knew it
was in for something extra special with
Fast Five and by special I'm referring
to two hours of window smashing bad guy
pummeling I think I'm on the right side
of the law of justice and as far as
hyped title cards go I say that epic
Clash between Dom Toretto and Hobbes was
worth it what the hell is his full name
was it Roy Hobbs big mistake kid
no no that's Bob Radford from the
natural but in the same way that the
stadium lights shattered during that
most epic home run seeing the rock
Elevate this franchise from a racing
movie set to a full-blown action-packed
nitrous oxide boost rocket jet fueled
pack with something to behold for kicks
I also love in fate of the Furious when
it's clear that rubber bullets are no
match for a guy who wakes up at 4am to
lift and is still in the gym at noon
once Dwayne stepped out on his own in
the hobsonshaw spin-off we were treated
to the best prison brawl this side of
the raid too and that final tussle with
Statham and Johnson merging forces to
defeat an Idris Elba that definitely
would have an asterisk next to his name
if he broke Hank Aaron's Home Run Record
you gotta love it let's go unplug this
other climactic clashes worth the wait
include Walking Tall where he takes down
a very frisky Neil McDonough Doom where
we get traded to a um I'll say plot
twist and even in the Scorpion King it
gets good when it's king versus
Balthazar I've come for the woman
and your head the special effects maybe
not quite ready to match the Ambitions
of the script but enjoyable nonetheless
speaking of Big Time endings the Marine
does at least show the potential for
John Cena taking his wrestling skills
and translating them well to mass
audiences of the movies he also gets his
hands dirty against Vin Diesel in fast
nine and The Suicide Squad features an
all-time Rumble in the Jungle Vibe
slobberknocker when it's Peacemaker
against Rick Flagg Dave Batista for all
his Brawn has more memorable scenes for
me that involve his Funny Bone but I
will give nod to the bones that he broke
along the way in sequences like
specter's train fight the casino war and
army of the dead and even that funny
storified in stuber plus we at least got
to give an honorable mention to master Z
Ip Man Legacy Batista's got a good fight
in there but that whole movie says
wall-to-wall popcorn munching excitement
there's huge chunks of the Guardians
movies that Spotlight Drax not as a
brute but as a unique thoughtful huge
comic relief nothing goes over his head
at least not according to him and while
Guardians too may have tried a little
too hard to out giggle its predecessor
you can't help but fall in love with
Drax and his mocking of Peter Quill a
little bit more you just need to find a
woman who is pathetic
like you
but what's that good God that's John
Cena's music and he's doing a new move
called the butt chug not working dude I
can't it's near the end of blockers and
what was a funny movie up to that point
shifted into fifth gear with that gag
look I enjoy my drinking sports but I
had never heard of that and I went to
college in North Carolina where we're
pretty inventive with our Oak sodas
don't try this move at home kids stick
with flip cup additionally Cena
improvised some really good lines in
train wreck and the dude can be laugh a
minute in season one of The Peacemaker
that dude's out for peace no matter how
many men women and children he has to
kill to get it as long as we spare the
eagle who's daddy's boy but as
impressive as these Two Fellas have been
in their comparatively short time on the
Silver Screen there's a reason The Rock
has been so consistently great for
decades now he can also handle a
non-action scene with the perfect touch
a nice transition from ass kickery to
funny bone tickery is the other guys
there goes my hero onto the pavement
Pain and Gain also features laughs at
his muscle-bound expense but Moana it's
all heart and humor his songs his
presence he's cool just not as cool as
he thinks he is and that opening scene
of Central Intelligence the flashback to
high school it's up there with his buddy
Ryan Reynolds and just friends Dusty
body of work could mean many things when
we're talking about the combined might
and hunkery of Cena Batista and Johnson
together they're what maybe 900 pounds
of pure A-list stardom but the rock
ranging from Peck jumping silliness and
Journey 2 all the way to the Furious 7
line I am the calvary it's just too much
to ignore Dwayne had the lead the other
fellas caught up but now it's the rock
that wins round four and he reclaims the
outright advantage two to one to one
and now it's time for the Wild Card
round get in the ring hey that's a Guns
and Roses song one of the many recurring
themes today another is that so far
we've stuck with my initial notion of
tossing these three heavyweights into
battle based on their acting merits but
in news that I first learned last week a
little bit of some pro wrestling does
involve performance so let's get on
board the night train for Paradise City
and see who's in-ring exploits are
deserving of a possible match ceiling
point in our final round the rock
exploded under the wrestling scene in
the latter part of the 1990s and in a
short period of time he could stand
shoulder to shoulder with all-time
Legends like Andre the Giant Hulk Hogan
and Rowdy Roddy Piper born with brawling
ability in his bloodline Johnson issued
a football career after an injury and
leapt into the ring the lighting
audiences with his patented finisher the
people's elbow although I still
maintained that The Rock Bottom might be
a more effective tactic dude made this
stuff look really good and really
painful thank you so much for John Cena
he was able to bridge Johnson and
Batista simply by having massive WWE
beef with both of them they're braver
than I as I'd want no part of John's
attitude adjustment which started as a
type of fireman's carry and ended like a
kneeling takedown he also had the power
bomb in his Arsenal and more recently
preferred finishers like the step over
toehold face lock a move that I remind
my brother that we were lucky to already
have been adults by the time it came
into fashion
Batista took what was the demon bomb and
made it his own to the point where it's
now known as the Batista bomb you get a
spine Buster opener which leads to a
thumbs up but that won't last long like
Cisco and Ebert turning on a movie the
thumb goes down Roman Emperor style and
then leads to a power bomb into a
perfect pinning position and before the
opponent knows what happened they've
been felt by a guy who originally went
by the name Leviathan yeah it's not a
name you want your competition to have
earned the rock scored a Royal Rumble
win in 2000 then Cena and Batista would
both add two each to their resume from
2005 to 2015. it's here that I should
point out Vin Diesel's defeated all
three of these Fellas on the big screen
look I'm just saying it's all sports
entertainment and maybe we find a way to
get everybody to patch things up and get
rid of their little tips in time for
Fast and Furious 15 Jurassic Mars
we smelled The Rock's culinary skills
first then witnessed Batista have an
incredibly long reign as a champ by
holding the belt for 282 days between
2005 and 2006 but John Cena's stats have
only one rival Ric Flair they're tied at
total championships with 16 apiece so
how do we break this deadlock that we
have between our three competitors today
okay I know I got it coolest character
name Batista is going to set the bar at
Drax the Destroyer Cena can meet that
with Peacemaker but the rock okay so he
played boxer santoros in Southland Tales
Jack Bruno in Race to Witch Mountain but
he's taken this round and thus the match
by being referred to as Dr smolder
bravestone in Jumanji even Idris elba's
stacker Pentecost and Pacific Rim thinks
that name is pretty sweet Dwayne Johnson
wins the round and thus the match
I'm sure my decision making will be
questioned and in a decade I might
overrule my own self but for now I give
the slight Edge to the guy who is also
named David akoya in Rampage are you
kidding me his name's really cool but
again this is all just my opinion so
give me your take right now at Mark
Ellis live and stay tuned right here at
Rotten Tomatoes for everything from
movies to TV to streaming shows to some
other wrestlers who may become actors
thanks for watching versus I'm Mark
Ellis and that is the bottom line
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]